it is time for hatred mail hatred mail
of course when a professional voice-over
artist does interpretive readings
interpretive narration of the hatred
mail the hate mail that I get quick
reminder about hatred mail because we
cling to our guns and our God but
somehow totally cool with a billionaire
who wants to assault our wife patriot
man written by Patriots who hate David
Pakman because America and because
freedom all right let's get right to it
this per I think that the person who
wrote this one to me may not really like
my perspective on politics take a listen
his name scrawny loser jealous lowlife
aka David Pakman is president Trump
David Pakman is a loser jealous idiot we
will fix things by getting liberal hacks
like David Pakman to lose again David
Pakman obviously drank lots of fluoride
and ate from BPA line plastic his whole
life
effeminate loser I actually really
present this hatred I didn't drink lots
of fluoride I got the right amount of
fluoride the exact right amount and as a
results my teeth are healthy
it's a beautiful thing remember that you
can fight hate reott ism in your local
community by using the coupon code
patriot 40 when you sign up for a
membership at join pakman.com save 40%
and make hey tree its cry with the
coupon code h 80 our i OT 4-0